chris hogan here i spent a lot of time
traveling speaking and talking with
people all around the country a topic
that continues to get me fired up is the
self-made millionaire and their success
story
I've even devoted segments of my
podcasts retire inspired to talking with
these self-made millionaires you're
about to step into the life of someone
who crossed over to millionaire status
on their own terms
that isn't a continuing vision that
isn't something that you can continue to
grow in that's a one-and-done kind of
dream and I think one and done isn't
enough you don't want to miss it people
this is millionaire we met in the back
view of a church
[Music]
part of my misspent youth was hanging
out of radio stations over the weekends
and I hadn't been in church for two and
a half years and it was my first Sunday
night off about in two and a half years
and went down very back pew at the other
end of the pew was this rather
attractive taller older and turns out
richer water were Pauline Lane she's
obviously Lane I'm obviously Paul where
he lives south of Seattle on a little
lake with a view of Mount Rainier and it
has been home and it is being paradise
for the last 21 years so originally we
math and we were doing it married within
the first year and you realized there
was a bunch of things that we needed to
do as singles before we got married so
by the time we actually got married it
was five years later our family was
ready to say really you guys are fun to
get married by that point in time we
didn't have a bar loans to pay off
because we had actually got that all
paid off before we got married
we did it poorly but we realized we
needed some kind of spending plan or
budget you make what you had due for
another month or so we also only had one
car and I'm big fan of public
transportation and then one of the
things I do a lot of I enjoy cooking and
so that was another thing where if we
wanted to spend time with people we had
people in versus they're going out to
restaurants all the time something to
the degree that there was peer pressure
we saw a lot of friends giving to some
awfully nice houses or getting into
their first houses when we were still on
our second apartment and there's an
emotional toll to that I think we've
always had this sense that the long view
matters
I remember paychecks that were almost
not worth captured those are tough
moments particularly if you've got a
young wife and you're you're thinking
about what the future might look like if
you've got enough money to pay for the
essentials in those early years taking
that long view and just you know a
dollar here dollar there
ten bucks becomes twenty bucks and then
all of a sudden the money starts working
for you rather than against you and
there's no magic moment but at some
point it kicks in and you realize that
you're not swimming against the current
anymore
a small paycheck in your 20s or your 30s
shouldn't cost you your dream it tests
the goal I mean if it's not worth
sacrificing for then it's not a good
enough goal yet
and the long view really matters it and
it it's the little stuff changing the
habits making new habits when you're not
making very much money at all
the first time there's money left at the
end of a paycheck that's a really cool
moment we're celebrating and and
recognizing for what it is it is the
beginning of a habit that will serve you
well in the long view
[Music]
it is really easy to get consumed by
that next thing that's a really cool
piece of electronics that is a wicked
good-looking car that's a really nice
planned neighborhood but does any of
that fit with your own sense of yourself
or sense of the long view that long view
may take you to another country may take
you to another career path it may take
you to early retirement
it may take you to to work until you're
70 but the truest thing that you have is
a sense of what you can do and what is
God doing through you in the long view
we started investing in the Canadian
government's equivalent of an IRA and
and what was cool about that it was a
huge lesson in the power of compounding
I mean how money actually was growing
now that was enormous ly cool and and
provided a lot of incentive but if you
do this then good things happen that and
which made the the sacrifice feel right
but when we moved here for grad school
our modest savings were now worth 72
cents on the dollar and it's a funny
thing about investing vetti it works on
both sides of the border and it works
overtime and that grew and grew and
growth and the thing about all of that
of course the math says that it speeds
up as you go the last little while has
been exciting any it's I don't know that
we've got our head around the that
status but it does keep us going in the
direction of financial independence
which has been the endgame students at
the beginning one of the things that we
have found is uncommon or turmoil Paul's
very long term Paul actually made me a
little picture thing look for my wallet
and you know after you buy this cute
little thing you won't get the house and
the trip to overseas and now I have a
bunch of co-workers that are retired
and so now it's like that's my
motivation to stay focus is that I want
to retire yeah one of the things we've
really got into us having a budget which
is really hard unfortunately I think a
budget is a bit of a swear word but
having that budget is how we got to
where we're at right now so if we're
really modest incomes we started putting
away what we could and then the magic of
compounding started kicking in we we saw
from having had credit cards that
compound interest can hurt you quickly
on the debt side but it started to look
really sweet when you saw what compound
interest could do for even modest
savings we're now twenty eight years
into this and compounding interest has
has grown up with us we've got the
flexibility to entertain all kinds of
options for what a third or fourth
career look might look like we
absolutely get that not everybody's got
that flexibility but we have been
investing in this little plan or
strategy for almost three decades and
its really gratifying but it it started
with you know 21 grand in here and and
putting aside ten bucks
[Music]
okay so we've made it to our last shoot
of the week this is number seven of
seven and it's with a Paul and Elaine
and they have a beautiful property here
on this wonderful lake and in the
distance is Mount Rainier and we're
ready to do this you guys know some of
this we are
[Music]
[Music]